you're into this thing now where you're
doing covers every time i see you you're
doing covers and i love that
i was blown out i'm watching a video of
you you did say hello to heaven which is
temple of the dog
i see you on that stage was it a charity
event or something is chris cornell's
tribute and that was one of the most
out-of-body experiences that i've never
really had one of those before
i'd never really done an event like that
before
the roster of people that were lined up
to do this you know when you look at a
list and it says what doesn't fit
i know i was the one that didn't fit i
think people were very confused about my
presence of being there
and i felt
really like moved his whole family was
there his daughters were there
his daughters actually come and visit me
on set when i was really young they grew
up watching my show and it brought them
together when he was now on the road
that was how they spent some time
and i really just felt moved by the
spirit of
how much love there was in in the room
for chris cornell and it
it really didn't come from me that
performance and
actually i walked off stage and i think
even my mom was like what the hell
happened because it sounded nothing like
it did at soundcheck
and that was one of the moments where
you realize
it's not about you it's about that
audience and when you're in a room
with what is unifying people is their
love for chris cornell and his talent
it really changed the way that i was
performing well what i love about that
video is i think there's an attitude
about you because you're young
and because you've had pop heads and
because you did hannah montana
the crowd is like [ __ ] her yeah exactly
yeah who is this coming out here and
doing temple of the dog stuff and uh
we're not buying into this and i think
it's one of those weird situations where
you've got to totally win over a
negative audience
and i mean to a person what i think
happened is once you opened your mouth
and you started singing that song
i think the whole crowd turned and was
like wow this is fantastic i i'll bring
you back for the moment
crowd was eating this thing up and i
loved it i mean it was so great it was
like one of those movies where the
unpopular kid wins over the crowd
and then i love those yeah the nerd
shows up to prom with an electric guitar
and everyone was like what the hell is
going on just rips it up and
all the girls get their tits out it's
like that was that moment for me
well what was great too is like you walk
out and you go okay let's get this
started
and how to be a great moment for you
yeah i really love that
performance just because i never
experienced anything like that and that
was different because a lot of my covers
i kind of customize it for myself
and that one was just in its original
form and i really did all his little
ad-libs and runs and
it was just a really intense experience
as a performer to do that but yes
it felt like i had to convert everyone
and it was it was a little
intimidating
you